so
i am a psych doctor
trained as large as a psychiatrist
but
as you said i am a
neuropsychopharmacologist and that is
someone that studies the effects of
pharmacology on the brain
why do i do that because the brain is a
chemical organ your brain communicates
all the neurons in your brain
communicate with each other by chemicals
80 different chemicals in the brain
and in order to understand the brain you
have to understand the chemicals and to
understand the chemicals you have to use
drugs to manipulate them
so as part of my work and my research i
i think i've achieved something that's
rather special i think i have
administered more different kinds of
drugs
to human beings than anyone alive
pretty much every class of drug that has
ever been given to someone to change the
brain i've given and so i know quite a
lot about drugs in the brain and that's
why the government
20 years ago asked me to join them to
advise them on drug policy because i was
an expert on drugs
but after 10 years of doing
research on the harms of drugs i came to
the conclusion which wasn't surprising i
suppose
that current drug policy and the current
drug laws weren't based on evidence
and then i started saying that publicly
and they didn't like that so they sacked
me
that is so funny but look what a lot of
people don't know the the the actual
scientific evidence um i suppose there
will be things lots of us don't know
can you talk to us about
which drugs are actually harmful
including the legal and the legal ones
and which drugs are less harmful than
others so we can kind of get a picture
of if everything was allowed to be taken
which drugs would be doing the most
damage and which would be the safest
sure well we did a very very systematic
analysis there are 16 ways in which
drugs can harm you wow there are nine
harms to the user and they range from
killing you as soon as you take it like
fentanyl or you know making you go
slightly crazy perhaps like uh like a
psychedelic
and then there are seven harms to
society
so if you if all drugs were illegal and
and they were equally used the most
dangerous drugs which would harm the
most number of people would be drugs
like heroin fentanyl crack cocaine
crystal meth
but then quite soon after you'd come to
alcohol alcohol is about the fifth or
sixth most harmful drug to the user
and the thing i got really angry with
about with the government was that the
drugs which are relatively less harmful
drugs like ecstasy like lsd like magic
mushrooms they're the ones that attract
the highest penalties even though
they're much less harmful than drugs
like even alcohol
you you say that i'm
i'm going to ask you this question and
i've wanted to ask it to you for a very
long time so when i started in comedy i
was a fan of bill hicks
the comedian and when he used to have
this routine about have you ever noticed
it's the drugs that do the least for you
that are legal the ones that get you to
question to push back to think for
yourselves are made illegal
do you agree with that totally genius he
was a genius absolutely completely on
track
the drugs that make you question
is the establishment equestrian
governments drugs like psychedelics they
were banned lsd was banned because
people were questioning the war in
vietnam
and because at that time as is still the
case today the only response of western
governments to drugs is to ban them they
got banned
it didn't affect people using them but
it absolutely hammered people like me
who want to research them and want to
use them as therapies and why is it that
we just can't have a very simple
rational discussion about this without
invoking p you know people getting very
angry upset you know blanket bans which
have been proven time and time again not
to work
well that's a really interesting
question why can't we have a rational
discussion
it's because i think now it's been so
long
that we've been lying about the harms of
drugs that
the people even people who kind of know
intellectually
that they are like these the the
relative harms of lie you know the drugs
that are banned because of lies they
even the people that know the truth
kind of feel uncomfortable about telling
the truth and i think obviously a lot of
people do believe that lies and they do
believe that drugs like lsd are more
harmful than alcohol which is of course
completely wrong
and we've had this phrase obviously used
in the last year in particular which is
following the science yes right when it
comes to other things
have we been following the science on
drugs
no we've been actively denying the
science
and we've been denying the science
do you know what it was you know where
it all started
it started in
uh 1914 with the opium act
the opium act was brought in
at kind of at the behest of
pharmaceutical companies who didn't want
people using plant products they didn't
like people smoking opium they wanted
people to use the extr the pure extract
of opium which is called morphine which
they had patented and in fact they
patented other extracts like codeine and
heroin
so there was an
antipathy to using plant products then
it was sort of gaining control of the
market by the by big farmer particularly
as german pharma companies
but in order to get
opium banned
he couldn't just ban it because it was
competing with farming what they had to
do was create the fear of opium and that
was very easy you just created a fear of
chinese you know and in london you know
the east end of london where we are now
you know this was you know basically
chinese people living here we smoking
opium and they would create you know
hysteria was created about them being
evil people and they were corrupting
them you know particularly young women
getting them smoking opium and so that
the fear
you know that this
was generated around chinese people
smoking opi both in here and in the
states to get opium banned that was the
beginning of it and then then it rolled
on and the biggest sea change came with
the uh the prohibition of america
uh of arco in america and that was
driven by right very puritanical
individuals you know lobby groups and
they were concerned quite understandably
concerned about the damage that alcohol
was doing to families
so rather than
have a rational policy to alcohol which
would be through taxation and limiting
access they banned it
and it wasn't just america sweden norway
finland also banned alcohol we nearly
did in this country
people don't realize in in i think it
was in the 1923 election
winston churchill stood in dundee
against the temperance candidate and the
temperance candidate beat churchill by i
think about 15 000 votes
so there's a huge international pressure
to ban alcohol anyway the americans
succumbed alcohol got banned what
happened
well hell let loose
organized crime rose because people like
alcohol and people weren't prepared to
give it up just to protect possibly
protect you know the families that were
being damaged hey well what's that got
to do with modern drugs well what
happened was in 1932 i think or 33
the prohibition act got repealed
but at that point because prohibition
was so corrupting of the police every
policeman in america was on the take
from speakeasies because every street
corner had to speak easy underground you
get your boos
so the police were all corrupt so the
american government created a special
army which we now call the drug
enforcement agency to fight the mafia
and just try to stop people using
alcohol
and that ended up being about 35 000
people
run by a man called harry anslinger
and suddenly one day
he knew that alcohol was going to be
legal so he couldn't be fighting alcohol
anymore he'd lose his job and all his
men would lose his job so what did he do
he created a new monster which was
cannabis and he changed the name from
cannabis to marijuana
because it's mexican and then he started
the classic process that all governments
do when they're they want to ban a drug
they associate it with some other group
in this case the mexicans and then the
same stories the stories we had about
the chinese corrupting
white people became the mexicans were
correctly white people the mexicans were
coming into america and selling cannabis
and young men were going crazy and they
were killing their mothers etc so he
created a hysteria about cannabis
but worse than that
he persuaded the rest of the world to be
hysterical about cannabis and in 1934
the league of nations
which america wasn't even part of
banned cannabis effectively worldwide
and that really started the whole chain
you know chain reaction of just keep
banning any drug you don't like until we
got to
the 1968 war on drugs with nixon where
you know he just went right over the top
in order to get elected
and and
we're talking about it now but it does
seem that we're starting to have a more
balanced approach
starting for example new york have i
think they've legalized cannabis
have they not do you think that's part
of a wider trend david that we're seeing
now
yeah well the debates happened i think
to be honest my sacking was made a
contribution in this country to the
debate because people said well why has
it been sacked and they said because
he's saying that
alcohol is more harmful than lsd
and the cannabis should be illegal
because it's less harmful than alcohol
and people started saying really oh but
he's a scientist oh oh maybe maybe he's
right you know
you know we have the you know we had the
ex-postman the secretary allen johnson
sacking me saying i think i was wrong on
the harms of cannabis i mean who are you
going to believe
you know you're going to believe at
least me because i have done some
research you know i
do have a sort of integrity and i do
have some knowledge
[Music]